aujourd'hui on va faire un épisode de
probablement un peu spécial puisqu'il
n'y aura pas d'invité et en fait on en
profitait pour faire un bilan sur
acheter des bateaux mieux donc j'ai déjà
faire un bilan public de hashtag de
bâton de mieux en fait ils demander plus
aux gens de faire des retours sur le
bilan que je faisais du dahu bateau
milieu dans une vidéo de la série à
chaque bateau mieux
donc c'est pas exactement ce qu'ils ont
à faire et aujourd'hui on va faire
aujourd'hui c'est on va vraiment
beaucoup plus parler de mes problèmes et
je vais insister un petit peu plus sur
ce qui ne va pas aujourd'hui avec
hashtag débat tant mieux et qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour essayer de faire
en sorte que ça aille mieux
alors j'ai quand même pas être trop
négatif par rapport à tout ça
globalement je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
de petit rat positif de hashtag le bâton
mieux le côté le plus positif d'acheter
des bateaux mieux celui qui est à peu
près évident pour moi c'est en tout cas
que j'ai énormément progressé
en fait je me suis vraiment rendu compte
de l'étendue de mon ignorance sur
comment bien débattre façon générale
c'est vrai que j'étais parti un peu sur
l'idée qu'il fallait faire de telle ou
telle manière que les vidéos de joseph
monsieur suffisait à à voir comment il
fallait bien débattre des petit à petit
en fait j'ai découvert énormément de
choses cours de cette dernière année le
plus marquant fut sans doute la
découverte du livre feeling good de
david byrne qui met un peu mal retourné
sur le cerveau sur pas mal d'aspects de
mieux débattre pour vous raconter
l'histoire angola parfois j'ai entendu
parler de ce livre c'était avec via
alexandre techno prog qui m'en avait
parlé donc lui vit énormément de livres
il me sert un petit peu de bibliothèques
et de des systèmes de recommandations de
livres et un jour il m'a dit bon voilà
sont pour à chaque bateau mais faut
vraiment que tu utilises ça et en effet
ça a vraiment été une révélation pour
moi ce livre vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
appris en le disant
d'ailleurs j'ai déjà fait quelques
vidéos à ce sujet mais peut-être le plus
marquant donc conduit individuel c'est
le rôle de lego c'est alexandre m'a
parlé de ce livre ma première réaction
c'est f entendent un exemple en
particulier de ce livre ma première
réaction était que c'était complètement
utopiste que c'était complètement
impossible en tout cas pour moi
de débattre comme le suggèrent des
beatles
une dame ambassades demande un travail
sur son propre ego et je pensais que
j'avais un ego beaucoup trop sur
dimensionné pour espérer un jour de
battre comme le conseil des vides baines
est en fait petit à petit en ligne en
lisant ce livre en fait je les plus
écoutés que lui qu'on écoute on se livre
sur audi bonne que j'entends vivant
c'est d'écouter vraiment s'excuser mais
pas lire écouter david byrne très bien
aussi peut-être pas aussi bien mais ça
marche quand même très très bien bref en
tout cas en et en écoutant david byrne
je me suis vraiment rendu compte en fait
que c'est pas forcément aussi difficile
que ce que j'espérais mais surtout
c'était assez ludique
il y avait vraiment quelque chose de
rigolo d'amusant de faim aussi un
sentiment de progrès personnels et de
plénitude de développement personnel
finalement à essayer de travailler sur
son propre ego eux de laisser de dire
finalement le lego est ce que c'est
vraiment quelque chose dont j'ai
vraiment besoin ce que finalement il
n'ya pas des trucs que je préfère
préférez plutôt que défendre mon ego et
et il ya des causes qui me semble
aujourd'hui bien plus important que que
défendre nego et deivid basma vraiment
convaincu de cela
et du coup vous parle en prenant
beaucoup plus loin de connaître par
exemple beaucoup plus important que mon
ego maintenant à mes yeux et à la
qualité de mes réflexions aussi qui est
plus important que mon ego à mes yeux
mais également des trucs plus altruistes
comme enfin de bien-être de l'humanité
le futur de l'humanité globalement je me
suis rendu compte qu'en fait le jeu en
vaut largement la chandelle et que ça
valait vraiment le coup de maître
beaucoup plus en avant mon bonheur ou
des choses comme le bien être de
l'humanité
et une fois que se dit vraiment c'est
que le but c'est vraiment mon bonheur
personnel sentiment d'épanouissement
personnel et le bien-être de l'humanité
on se rend compte qu'il ya vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup de progrès à faire
dans la manière dont ceux dont on débat
et que dans la manière dont je débats
j'ai largement beaucoup trop tendance à
naître mon petit ego en avant voilà je
pense que c'est vraiment le truc que
j'ai sur lequel j'ai fait une grosse
mise à jour cours de cette réflexion
autour de débats tant mieux il ya plein
d'autres choses je veux plus en plus
préoccupée par tout ce qui est phénomène
effet de groupe
je pense que les effets de groupe sont
très très néfaste à débattre mieux en
particulier mais également à nos
sociétés et du coup d'autres mises à
jour que j'ai fait au cours de ces
dernières années
c'est l'attention particulière à ne pas
subir cet effet de groupe où ne pas
causer cet effet de groupe les deux
comptent donc ça m'arrive souvent en
fait de réagir un truc parce que je me
sens où je sens que c'est la communauté
qui est impliqué et que je dois défendre
la communauté
aujourd'hui j'ai beaucoup beaucoup moins
ce sentiment très peu de communautés
aujourd'hui cuvée il devait sentir le
besoin de défendre même si le crétier
les bayésiens of each peuvent donc pas
qu'ils sélection ça va très très bien de
critiquer les barisiens même si je sais
pas trop de qui ça parle mais voilà
c'est une critique et un baiser en
particulier qu'on est pas du tout
personnellement je pense qu'ils sont
extrêmement fallacieux bail si vous
critiquez la le très efficace
il ya plein de choses qui se passent au
mouvement du mouvement est très efficace
qui sont largement prépare effectivement
pu moi je pense que non puisqu'il il
trouve que les gens de la très efficace
on traiterait en faveur de critiquer des
trucs qui se passent dans la très
efficace ils ont également cette
tendance
donc c'est pas du tout gênant de
critiquer alto efficace et quelques
quelques déclarations de quelques jandal
très efficace que je trouve pas
productive
ça me va l'argent de 2,2 et critiquer
même si globalement je pense que le
mouvement est très bénéfique
voilà pareil si vous critiquez les
sciences si vous critiquez les
mathématiciens si vous critiquez à les
vulgarisateurs la sphère youtube
je pense que tout ça ça me va très bien
de critiquer tous âges et plus autant
qu'avant ce sentiment de devoir défendre
les biens ou les moules et où les nôtres
et je pense même que ça c'est néfaste
d'avoir ce réflexe donc ouais ça sonne
des grosses mises à jour que j'ai fait
cette année sur lequel je pense avoir
beaucoup progressé
donc et donc ça c'est le côté participé
à des effets de groupe
et puis aussi le fait de causer des
effets de groupe c'est d'être beaucoup
plus méfiant par rapport à des effets de
groupe que je pourrai cause et je pense
ne pas être encore très très bon quand
on regarde les vidéos précédentes
il ya un côté groupistes qui ressort un
peu ou appel appel à la meute ou autres
cas même notation très inconsciente un
petit ne cherche pas faire des effets
des appels à la meute de façon
inconsciente basse et c'est quand même
quelque chose qui ressort de mes vidéos
et j'en suis vraiment pas content donc
voilà si trop travailler c'est des rares
vidéos et donc les prochaines vidéos je
vais faire vraiment vraiment gafa a
diminué ses effets de groupe a essayé
d'éviter de dire nous les balises ont
par exemple où les parisiens pensent que
je pense que c'est très très mauvais
d'avoir ce genre de discours et va
falloir que je travaille beaucoup sur ça
donc c'est des trucs je fais très très
mal
autre cas voilà c'est je pense ces deux
grosses mises à jour par rapport à il ya
un an
c'est vraiment ce côté travailler sur
les égos quoi et finalement légaux c'est
finalement pas si important ça peut être
intéressant d'un point de vue
instrumental de défendre son ego mais en
fait souvent même pas tant que ça et le
fait de défendre son ego et sous
jour-même instrumentalement
contre-productif parce qu'après on passe
pour le maître queux qui ne pense qu'à
lui donc en fait on défendre son négoce
quelque chose de vraiment pas important
et en fait c'est surtout très secondaire
par rapport à d'autres choses comme par
exemple mon propre bien-être et puis
l'autre mise à jour donc faire beaucoup
plus attention à ces phénomènes de
groupe c'est l'effet de groupe cette
polarisation de groupe
voilà ça c'est un peu les deux grandes
mises à jour d'acheter que va-t-on bien
sûr lequel j'essaie de beaucoup
travailler
donc ça c'est vraiment au niveau
individuel après on y voit un peu plus
collecté je pense qu'il ya eu aussi des
dérives de débat tombe mieux qu'ils ont
lieu et qui sont dommages et qui sont
pas mal ma faute mais qui ne sont pas à
ce qu'il y ait eu des choses qui ont été
reprises et je pense qu'en fait c'est
important que comme malheureusement
hashtag de bâton de mieux est encore
associé à moi que je fasses ses appels à
tous ceux qui réutilise le hashtag
débattre mieux bas juste réfléchir un
peu plus à quelles sont les meilleures
façons de concevoir attaques de bateaux
mieux donc à un des points assez
clairement c'est que hashtag de bâton
bien et a été vu comme moralisateur ou
j'ai beaucoup de retours de gens qui
m'ont dit que il avait cette impression
de qualité est au mieux et et
moralisateur et c'est pas leur faute
c'est clairement le mouvement hashtag de
bâton mieux qui est qui est en tort
jusque le jem pas simple non plus parler
de ces notions de thor france que
c'était un peu une erreur aussi de
parler de torts mais clairement hashtag
doit être mieux doivent lui faire un peu
mieux faire et doit mieux faire une
marge de progression tous ceux qui
promeuvent hashtag de la tombe mais en
particulier moi faut faire beaucoup plus
gaffe ne pas passer pour moralisateur et
clairement on et moralisateur réforme
clairement il ya un côté on veut changer
la manière dont les gens ont des
discussions sur sur twitter sur les
réseaux sociaux
dans la vraie vie irl on veut avoir des
meilleures discussions et on va amener
les gens à avoir de meilleures
discussions du coup faut changer le
comportement des gens et sac à main ces
moralisateurs jeu va falloir être un peu
moralisateur d'un côté donc c'est pas la
volonté moralisatrice que je vais
critiquer ici mais c'est plus le fait de
paraître moralisateur en fait je pense
qu'on peut largement encouragé des
changements de comportement sans
paraître moralisateur
typiquement en insistant davantage sur
les opportunités montré en passant moins
moralisateur est typiquement un des
trucs que je vais essayer de faire que
que je pense avoir mal fait jusque là
c'est essayer d'inciter beaucoup plus
sur les opportunités sur le le bien
qu'il y a à a
mieux débattre à mieux converser de ces
différents sujets et je pense qu'il ya
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de choses on
peut mettre beaucoup plus en avant par
donc le bien-être plutôt que les égos et
ça ce sera bien pour le bien-être de
beaucoup de gens y compris ceux qui sont
je met des gros guillemets victimes
entre gros guillemets de htds va tomber
à ceux qui sont plus d'hommes à dire
ciblés avec des gros guillemets hong
kong voix par à chaque débat tant mieux
je pense que il ya beaucoup plus à
gagner en montrant que en ayant beaucoup
plus une fois élections autour de
hashtag et batum lieu il est capable
d'apporter beaucoup de bien-être à des
gens aujourd'hui qu'ils n'ont pas la
meilleure façon de débattre c'est
beaucoup plus insisté sur les objectifs
et les opportunités
je pense que si on réfléchit un peu plus
à grande échelle et sur le long terme
les les enjeux sont juste énormes mon
sens aujourd'hui on est vraiment dans
une société où malheureusement donne pas
assez de temps de réflexion sur des
sujets importants et de qualité et de
réflexions sur des sujets importants et
pour y arriver
bah deux façons soit ça répare pas de
façon magique il faut que quelque part
des changements de comportement et de
réflexion autour de ces sujets est
vraiment à chaque voiture neuve avaler
dans enfin le but c'est d'aller dans ce
sens d'amener les gens à mieux réfléchir
à des sujets plus importants et avoir
cette réflexion collective parce que
sans réflexion collective c'est très
très difficile de bien réfléchir
donc je pense qu'il est vraiment achève
à tomber doit être vu comme un
encouragement avoir de meilleure
réflexion et des bonnes réflexions sur
des sujets qui sont vraiment fascinant
et un des gros travaux sur lequel j'ai
envie de travailler cette année sur deux
débats tant mieux c'est d'amener les
gens associés des bâtons mais avec les
chose de positive quelque chose de 2
d'enthousiasmant voir quelque chose qui
apporte beaucoup au développement
personnel qui rend heureux
je pense que c'est super important que
chaque bateau mieux soit associé à être
heureux et c'est pour ça que typiquement
promouvoir des livres comme celui de
david byrne sont très très importants
parce que david byrne ça se fait c'est
un livre sur la claque de bâton mieux à
mon sens mais sous l'angle de être plus
plus être être plus heureux et est plus
épanouie et donc je pense que vraiment
l'objectif doit être beaucoup plus
tournée vers être vers l'épanouissement
personnel le bonheur le calme la
méditation le tout ce qui est positif
derrière tout ça il ya énormément à
gagner à être beaucoup plus dans cet
état d'esprit et en étant dans cet état
d'esprit il me semble aussi que on est
capable de promouvoir aussi des bâtons
mieux de manière beaucoup plus efficace
donc j'utilise aussi des anglais des
langages qui sont assez des connexions
très différente parce qu'il est très
important de nous soucier du matin au
mieux à ces condamnations très très
positive mais également bas je pense
rester aussi sur la terminologie des
bâtons mieux qui malheureusement as un
côté assez agressif dans nos débats at
on donc en partie qu'ils ont mis des
bâtons des gagnants au mieux il ya un
côté un peu agressif il me semble que
ces malheurs enfin c'est malheureux mais
c'est également utile parce que les
moments où on a le plus besoin d'être
dans cet esprit de développement
personnel personnel de bienveillance et
de calme bah c'est le moment où on va
vouloir se mettre en mode débat se
mettre à débattre et du coup il ya voir
se prendre de transférabilité qui
s'opposent
on a des n'est capable de bien réfléchir
sur des sujets assez théorique assez
abstrait et sur lesquels on veut
vraiment bien faire mais il faut
absolument réussir à transposer ses
qualités de réflexion et de débat à des
sujets beaucoup plus
contrôleur c'est beaucoup plus houleux
on a tendance à laisser un petit peu
notre hobby gagnent près entre le dessus
et c'est dommage parce que du coup on a
souvent des réflexions et des débats de
très mauvaise qualité sur des sujets qui
sont en fait les sujets les plus
importantes
donc c'est super important qu'il y ait
cette trente ce transfert de compétence
des sujets où on et n'a pas de problèmes
éthiques fondamentaux et du coup on peut
poser beaucoup plus au débat et il me
semble super important de transférer ses
capacités à des domaines où on aura
moins l'habitude d'avoir le contrôle sur
nos émotions et on a tendance à être
beaucoup plus se laisser beaucoup plus
emporté donc pour ce set transférabilité
il me semble important de rester sur des
notes qui sont un peu plus
moralisatrices un peu plus des bâtons
mieux vraiment un peu plus un peu plus
potentiellement un peu agressive c'est
d'éviter quand même mais malheureusement
je pense que c'est un petit d'être un
tout petit peu agressif mais pour que
des bâtons ne soit pas associé à quelque
chose d'agressif de méchants de
démoralisateurs est extrêmement
important que à côté de tout ça il y
également énormément d'efforts pour
faire en sorte que des bâtons mieux soit
beaucoup plus bienveillants associé à
quelque chose de positif quelque chose
de beaucoup de plénitude de bonheur de
d'épanouissement et de réflexion de
qualité de stimulation intellectuelle
j'aimerais aussi vraiment qui est
beaucoup plus de stimulation
intellectuelle associée à des bâtons
mieux du coup ça a été un de mes
objectifs est resté très transférables
mais tout en étant globalement très très
bénéfique très positive très très très
motivateur très très allez les gars on
va bien faire ces ensembles sa lettre au
culte va être chouette très très positif
quelque chose comme ça je pense que
c'est un des gros axe je vais beaucoup
travailler dessus
si vous voulez promouvoir hashtag de
l'atome jamais que souvent je pense que
c'est utile que y est c'est réfection
aussi que vous ayez cette réflexion et
avant de pouvoir des bateaux mieux
quelles sont vraiment les meilleures
façons de promouvoir des bâtons mieux
on m'a pas mal suggéré de donner des
exemples de bons débats pour essayer de
montrer aux gens qu'est ce que serait
qu'un second débat puis peut-être
d'analysé critique et c'est bon débat je
pense qu'il y en a pas mal en fait déjà
je conserve beaucoup des discussions
qu'ont qu'aucune autre sur probablement
pardon que les débats aussi qui me
terrel a été organisée autour de débats
tant mieux je considère que ce sont des
débats qui sont pas trop terrible
je pense que ces débats largement
améliorable et beaucoup de l'aspect
critiquable et d'ailleurs sont invités à
les critiquer vous même à ses devoirs
qu'est ce qui fait que dans ces débats
ça c'est quels sont les points de ces
débats qui ont pas été par exemple peu
productifs qui n'ont pas été efficaces
où il ya eu des tensions inutiles ou ou
et qu'est ce qui n'allait pas dans ces
débats aussi à réfléchir à quai ce qui
allait bien dans ces débats je pense
qu'il ya pas mal d'exemples de débat on
peut aller voir sur internet à toutes
les discussions qu'on a sur twitter il
ya pas mal de débats et malheureusement
on a tendance à avoir une attention qui
est tourné vers les débats et puis
virulents les plus recherchés tout ça il
ya beaucoup de débats qui se passe très
très bien sur twitter vous invite à
essayer de mettre en avant ses ces
débats réfléchir regarder d'inventaire
et chaussées débat peut être un but est
davantage les débats virulents pourvoir
être habitué à ses réflexes de bons
débats sinon bah il ya des livres aussi
que je recommande de vivement je vous
rappelle encore feeling good
il ya un livre sorti récemment que
s'appelle aussi à hauteur avant un
possible cas de cession je ne suis en
paix des hauteurs désolé mais à chercher
ça si vous voulez des exemples de bons
débats et de bons réflexes de débats je
vous invite vraiment réfléchir à tout ça
et je pense que je vais pas trop
travailler sur ça cette année notamment
parce que par les démons débat ça prend
beaucoup de temps faites faut suivre les
débats et si le débat en lui-même est
pas intéressant et qu'on s'intéresse
juste à la forme du débat ça peut être
un petit peu un petit peu chiant que
comme comme thème vidéo du coup vous
invite plus à regarder les débats qui
vous intéresse déjà les sujets de débat
qui intéresse déjà y en a plein est
vraiment à réfléchir à qu'est ce qui
fait que ces débats sont
mauvais qu'est-ce qui serait qu est ce
qui ce qui a vraiment mal tourné
qu'est-ce qui pourrait être émis durable
et quelles sont les solutions pour
améliorer ces débats de façon générale
voilà donc ça fait déjà pas mal de
réflexion autour de tout ça et bien d
autres trucs que j'avais abordé pendant
la table ronde c'est le fait que
un des aspects que je trouve
problématique aujourd'hui avec acheter
des bateaux mieux c'est que je sois
encore beaucoup associé à acheter du
bâton bio bon je vais nuancer un petit
peu cette critique en disant que ça me
dérange pas encore trop parce que je
pense que derrière hashtag de bâton
mieux c'est super important que d'il ya
beaucoup de réflexion que se soit calmée
qu'ils soient pas repris partout
n'importe qui comme ça a été le cas
pendant de nos sections
il faut fouiller une croissance de 16 à
une certaine manière de l'acheter le
bâton mieux qu'ils soient bien contrôlé
et bien maîtrisée et que voilà les gens
qui promeuvent acheter des bateaux mieux
le fond en ayant vraiment bien réfléchi
hashtag débattre mieux parce que je
pense qu'il ya plein de trucs contre
intuitif qu'on y réfléchisse un petit
peu des trucs qu'on croit être des
aspects de l'achat de bateaux mais
qu'ils sont pas forcément et du coup ça
me dérange pas que sa crosse ça soit ça
prolifère pas dans tous les sens
ceci dit et puis enfin de notre critique
que j'aurai à faire de moi même où je
fais cette 7e table ronde c'est que en
fait je suis pas du tout seul il ya pas
mal de gens qui promet déjà eu lieu
je m vraiment celui qui le fait le plus
en ce moment c'est alexandre techno prog
joconde est vivement vivement vivement
sa chaîne y beaucoup beaucoup de trucs
de très très grande qualité sur sa
chaîne vraiment vraiment aller voir
alexandre techno prog également sur sur
twitter où il agit beaucoup essayé de de
courage et les gens à voir deux des
meilleurs débat et puis beaucoup de
discussions entre entre alex et moi sur
toutes sortes de sujets en particulier
sur hashtag berthomieu donc vraiment vos
commandes vivement alexandre techno prog
bas sinon je veux retourner encore une
fois je lui aie aie aie fond
ma grande inspiration c'est vraiment ces
vidéos sont c'est vraiment des
traductions de ses vidéos que je dois
faire
d'ailleurs je t'invite à aller voir
directement sur sa chaîne et voir toutes
les vidéos qu'elle a fait il ya
malheureusement beaucoup de choses à
dire sur hashtag de bâton dieu c'est un
des trucs aussi qui me fera beaucoup
quand on parle de hashtag des bâtons bio
c'est que je pense qu'il ya pas mal
finalement d'excès de confiance chez
chacun d'entre nous sur ce qu'est un bon
débat on a tendance à penser qu'on sait
ce qu'est un bon débat et à penser que
l'on sait que qu'est ce qu'on devrait
faire pour mieux débattre alors qu'en
fait il ya plein de choses qui sont
ultra compétitive et malheureusement il
ya également ultra fins beaucoup
beaucoup de choses à dire donc julia
ghallef aborde beaucoup de ces sujets
donc je je recommande très vivement
d'aller voir ja guère parler de tout ça
sinon bye gênante à l'oci a beaucoup
fait des vidéos qui parle de discussions
notamment de la vidéo qui s'appelle le
sophisme du procureur notamment je
compte pas mal cette vidéo pour les
aspects où il parle de prendre en compte
ce que l'autre au cfc très important et
très très intéressant il le fait d'une
manière tout je suis pas capable de
faire
sinon il ya je crois aussi très vivement
la chaîne youtube qui s'appelle près de
anthony maniaque bosco si vous avez fond
si vous êtes des exemples de bons débats
allaient voir anthony magnier bosco qui
fait vraiment des trucs très intéressant
où il va parler à des gens dans la rue
et notamment il ya une vidéo
c'est de retrouver je sais plus comment
s'appelle we thought aux analyses
il analyse la discussion qu'il a eue et
c'est vraiment enfin c'est vraiment
fascinant c'est énormément de réflexes
qu'il faut promouvoir davantage et qui
sont extrêmement difficiles à avoir
faut vraiment s'entraîner à les avoir
accès sur important de trouver ça coule
de chercher à bien débattre parce que si
si vous trouvez pas ça cool vous n'avez
pas vu un vestiaire c'est comme les
mathématiques dont si vous trouvez pas
une mathématique au bout
vous pouvez pas passer les heures et les
jouets les nuits de réflexion
mathématique qui sont nécessaires pour
devenir bon en mathématiques
c'est pareil avec le hashtag bâton mieux
si vous passez pas beaucoup beaucoup de
temps à réfléchir car comment mieux
débattre
malheureusement le problème est
tellement difficile que ça me semble
compliqué pour fins de mieux débattre si
on s'entraîne pas si on y réfléchit pas
régulièrement vous invite à vraiment à
faire ça et là typiquement à aller voir
des gens qui font super bass a super
bien donc anthony m'a amené à bosco
vraiment choquant de très très très
vivement choquée en également beaucoup
mr chef sam point d'interrogation qui
est celui qui m'a fait découvrir
anthony maniable bosco et qui a
également fait beaucoup de contenus de
qualité même en particulier une qui
s'appelle comment raisonner quelqu'un
que je recommande vivement
et puis sinon ballon et enfin sur
twitter ou sur youtube ont également il
ya d'autres qui mettent en avant pas mal
ces façons de mieux des bâtons de mieux
réfléchir collectivement donc sébastien
carassou du cnsof vendeur il ya chez ces
petits qui a tranché en biais qui ont
fait des vidéos sur hashtags des bâtons
mieux l'esprit sorcier qui a réagi
également sur parfois des mauvais débat
qu'ils ont lu et à comment mettre en
avant une plus de bienveillance donc
dans ces discussions
vous n'allez quand même pas mal de gens
et c'est vraiment vraiment chouette qui
essaie de promouvoir sa encore plus mais
vraiment si vous voulez promouvoir à
toute allure et ont mieux j'ai vraiment
envie de dire qu'avant de promouvoir
l'achat doit être mieux au moment de
pouvoir acheter des bateaux mieux je
vous invite vraiment à réfléchir
vraiment l'engouement à comment mieux
débattre ans qu'on attend ça saute et
beaucoup trop vite cette étape et à
passer directement à appeler les gens à
mieux débattre mais il ya vraiment
beaucoup de choses à prendre en compte
avant de se lancer dans une promotion de
l'achat de bateaux de mieux vraiment
réfléchi chf de la tombe mieux et puis
informez vous j'ai envie de dire hd
n'est pas mal de références déjà dans
cette vidéo
je vous invite vraiment aller voir vous
familiariser avec les travaux des uns et
des autres parce qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de choses qui sont encore une
fois contre intuitive et si vous
promouvez hashtag de bâton mieux avec de
la mauvaise manière en fait ça peut être
assez facilement contreproductif
réfléchissez-y et surtout essayer de
trouver du plaisir dans ces réflexions
parce que y'a plein de fric contre
intuitif qui sont vraiment rigolo en
fait et et puis à beaucoup d'efforts à
faire soi-même de travail individuels
qui sont également rigolo cas si on
tourne tout ça que plus qu'un jeu le jeu
pour essayer de mieux débattre de mieux
promouvoir la bienveillance la réflexion
collective
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
progrès à faire
donc lancé vous mais faites gaffe c'est
un petit peu mon message et si vous êtes
arrivés là et que vous voulez vraiment
contribué n'hésitez pas aussi à me
proposer des collaborations je vais
ouvrir beaucoup plus à la collaboration
et les prochaines vidéos des échecs des
bâtons mieux j'aimerais vraiment que
enfin comme cela a été suggéré en fait
dans la table ronde je trouve ça une
super bonne idée de bass ici vous êtes
youtuber 0 particulier pas besoin d'être
idiot mais faut avoir un peu de matériel
pour s'enregistrer
j'ai envie de dire est que ce sera plus
facile pour moi aussi si six autres
personnes féfé boulot de d'édition de
vidéos mais si vous avez des contenus
nous on sait que c'est important pour
chaque doit-on mieux que vous voulez
promouvoir bas entre en contact avec moi
proposez moi un truc facile vous fait
d'être capable de faire la vidéo vous
mêmes bancs les traits de l'argent à la
ferme ou même et puis pour la diffuser
sur ma chaîne si c'est quelque chose que
vous voulez ce sera l'occasion aussi de
promouvoir votre chaîne et pour moi ça
serait super génial parce que ça
permettrait d'avoir d'autres visages
autour des attaques des bâtons mieux
donc vraiment vraiment
bon allez les gros youtuber je contacte
river mais ce que je connais pas
forcément où ce jeu quand même pas
forcément un intérêt pour acheter des
bateaux mieux vous invite vivement à
essayer de faire ça et pour encore mieux
promouvoir la réflexion collective
derrière acheter un bateau de mieux
beaucoup plus qu à chicago à son bios
typiquement s'associer la réflexion
collective a besoin que ça aille au
clash jusque on met des réflexions
collectives ensemble c'est comme ça que
les grands sujets de l'humanité du futur
de l'humanité pour être nous adresser il
me semble sinon pour les prochains
grands sujets à à venir sur sur ma
chaîne pour éviter de faire doublon ou
juste pour parce que peut-être que ça
m'intéresse de savoir de quoi je vais
parler bientôt sur la chaîne voyage et
pas toutes les idées en tête ça va venir
au fur et à mesure j'ai malheureusement
j'ai un document avec une centaine de
sujets prévus autour de la taille des
bateaux lieu j'espère que ça vous donne
un peu une idée de l'étendue de ce dont
je pense important de parler et du coût
de ce qui me semble être l'étendue de
l'ignorance chez beaucoup de personnes
et il faut bien se dire que je rajoute
des sujets très régulièrement à cette
liste ce qui montre aussi l'étendue de
ma propre ignorance
c'est un sujet extrêmement vaste il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup trop de
sujets à traiter on espère que ça c'est
ressorti également c'est l'impression
que vous avez vu on regarde on
le débat qu'on a eu autour de débats
tant mieux frames
il ya vraiment beaucoup trop de sujets
et je pourrai pas allés les attaquer
tout seul en espace d'un ton de l'année
qui vient ça prendra des années pour
aborder des décennies sans aborder tous
les sujets à aborder
donc voila j'aimerais vraiment content
que vous encourager à vous attaquez vous
même mais ça montre aussi l'importance
de plus de prioriser les différents
sujets c'est aussi un des trucs qui
apparaît souvent dans les débats que
j'ai sur acheter des bateaux mieux
chaque fois qu'il ya ce genre de débat
je trouve qu'on a du mal à prioriser les
sujets importants sur alta que la tenue
ou ce qui est important de communiquer
autour de racheter le vibrato mieux donc
un des aspects importants c'est vraiment
prioriser les des choses importantes
pour avoir encouragé les meilleurs
réflexion et du coup les trucs
importants qui vont sortir dans les
années n'ont cependant les dans les mois
à venir
je pense que on va faire beaucoup de
travaux sur recevoir les critiques
qu'ils aient quelque chose à chaud
attend ça mal réagir à la réception de
la critique et je pense que c'est un
truc que largement travaillé donc et
déjà eu que quelques vidéos là dessus
notamment la vidéo choisir nos émotions
et on va continuer je commence à parler
de choses qui sont un peu dans cette
longueur d'onde
essayez de voir je répare légalement
dans une vidéo sur fond de baisse mais
assez de voir chaque discussion comme
une opportunité alors c'est pas
forcément une opportunité énorme et du
coup pas probablement juste ne pas
engager la discussion est en fait une
façon de sélectionner ses débats à voir
et ça me semble très utile d'avoir cette
priorisation des sujets de discussion
typiquement en ignorant également des
sujets qui ne méritent pas notre
attention ça peut paraître un peu
violent il faut faire pour faire ça bien
faut éviter de dire non mais ça ne
m'intéresse pas faut essayer de contrer
ces sujets aux gens que c'est pas des
choses dont on aimerait parler mais je
pense que c'est important d'avoir cette
réception de la critique on dit dans mon
bar à soupes ont par exemple cette
critique ce que tu aimais tant que vous
émettez keitel personnes aimaient et
valide mais enfin c'est juste pas une
priorité
et il ya d'autres sujets on aimerait
parler c'est une façon de recevoir les
critiques pas ya des critiques qui sont
qui sont intéressants tant sur des
sujets importants et l'a peut-être que
d'autres façons de recevoir la critique
c'est de tourner toujours c'est une
opportunité je pense que c'est un des
reflex mais il ya beaucoup d'autres
choses à faire à trouver sur l'ego par
exemple a essayé de tourner la
discussion sur quelque chose de
collaboratif on va les papas mal de
réflexes comme ça va avoir un débat et
du coup je pense que c'est des sujets
sur lesquels le moi je peux j'aimerais
aborder un peu plus cette année dans
l'année qui vient
comme vous comme l'annoncé ici en début
de vidéo jeu beaucoup plus insister sur
les enjeux des débats c'est je pense à
mener toujours ça à des enjeux ou à des
questions plus prédictive ac 2-2
finalement ça revient à prioriser les
débats prioriser le sujet du débat a
essayé d'amener s'avère ce qui est
important aussi c'est de pouvoir aussi
beaucoup plus des idées autour d'une
nuit ou du double de la discussion
c'est l'idée d'essayer de clarifier
autant que possible et de se re année de
clarifier les points d'accord de et les
points de désaccord et surtout essayer
de trouver le point de désaccord le plus
intéressant en particulier un point de
désaccord c'est intéressant si pas
typiquement c'est une question très très
simple clairement on n'est pas d'accord
c'est souvent difficile de toi en fait
très simple mais vraiment très très très
simple et très très clairs sur lequel on
est on est en désaccord et ainsi à ce
point est idéalement c'est un point sur
lequel également ça dépend d'une données
empiriques et puis il suffit de regarder
sur wikipédia ou sur google et
l'information suffit à démêler le new du
débat c'est vraiment l'idéal attendre en
pratique c'est souvent plus compliqué
que ça mais voilà typiquement essayer
d'amener les gens à réfléchir à
qu'est-ce qui fait la distinction
également soldé pas mal de vidéos sur
amener les gens à réfléchir enfin
encourager la réflexion sur les gens
notamment la réflexion sur comment mieux
réfléchir et du coup souvent ramené sa
des questions un peu plus
d'épistémologie je pense qu'un autre
aspect important aussi c'est par rapport
à l'excès de confiance
réfléchir beaucoup plus en terme de quel
est mon objectif au cours du débat et si
l'autre personne est en excès de
confiance
c'est complètement illusoire d'espérer
faire changer d'avis à 180 degrés est et
en particulier souvent très mauvais
réflexe de mettre notre avis est de
montrer qu on est sûr de notre avis
parce que de personnes qui vont être en
excès de confiance est souvent sortie
c'est pas terrible
on fait souvent ce qui est assez utile
c'est essayer de semer d'abord le doute
de 6 d'amener la personne à réfléchir
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle a un tel niveau
de certitude
est ce que ce n'est aux incertitudes est
vraiment justifiée
et du coup c'est plus essayer d'amener
la personne à réfléchir à pourquoi est
ce qu'elle croit ce qu'elle croit ce qui
est beaucoup plus modeste ans que doit
faire de me changer d'avis et en fait si
on arrive à aller faire ça on peut
considérer que la réflexion a été
extrêmement productive je pense que
c'est important aussi de de modifier les
objectifs que l'on a en fonction du
temps que l'on a avec la personne et de
fin de l'état de connaissances son état
épistémique actuelle si la personne est
très très très convaincu d'un truc et du
coup elle est en excès de confiance sur
un point va peut-être juste l'amener à
réduire cet excès de confiance
de même d'un tout petit peu et de
d'entamer une réflexion ça suffit
largement
et en plus souvent ça peut suffire à
entamer chez elle une réflexion qui
durera plusieurs jours
essayez de réfléchir beaucoup à à tout
ça comment lutter contre contre des
critiques qui sont contrôlés que cette
conférence je pense que c'est un des
points c'est important
il y aura des vidéos à venir cette année
sur cette question un autre point six
ans que j'aimerais insister sur lequel
j'aimerais insister aussi dans l'année
qui vient c'est tout ce qui est faux
c'est de réception ouais c'est un terme
que j'ai inventé l'idée que entre la
manière dont sont exprimés une idée
en particulier la réception qu'on
s'attend à avoir de ce qu'on vient
d'exprimer et la réelle perdre ce que
l'acception qui va y avoir il ya souvent
un fossé
on est beaucoup trop optimiste sur la
réception de votre message
une fois que j'aurai dit cela ça va
changer faire changer d'avis tout le
monde alors que france pense à elles
sont n'observe pas ce changement de
david juste après avoir émis un tel avis
et ça c'est finalement une erreur dans
l'erreur d'autre part c'est pas
forcément d'avoir émis exprès la vie
qu'on a exprimé mais l'erreur de notre
part c'est beaucoup plus d'avoir imaginé
que ce qu'on a exprimé allait avoir un
impact tel qu'on l'imaginé souvent
l'impact de ce qu'on a dit et pas du
tout celui qu'on imagine et ça ça vient
tout simplement du fait qu'on est très
mauvais pour prédire la manière dont nos
messages seront reçus et comme je pense
que c'est très important de prendre de
ça on comptait 2 beaucoup plus travaillé
la prédiction sur la réception de nous
de nos différents messages et il y aura
pas mal de vidéos sont sans doute pas
mal là dessus voilà donc ça c'est
aujourd'hui ou jeudi les vidéos à venir
mais enfin ouais j'ai une telle
ignorance le sujet que et je lis
régulièrement beaucoup de choses à ce
sujet et il ya beaucoup de choses qu'il
me faut encore lire je vais pas fini le
bouton on off shore avait une possible
convocation et on m'a beaucoup aussi
recommander une série de blogs du billet
de blog de wight peu trahi le tir et je
n'ai pas encore lu donc il faut que j'en
ai lu ça c'est encore changer d'avis sur
comment mieux débattre et du coup il y
aura beaucoup de changements mais un des
trucs que j'ai pour le coup m'a beaucoup
demandé mais je sais que je vais pas le
faire ces temps que je sais que je pense
ne pas le faire c'est parler des formats
de débats où les plates formes de débat
ils sont cette critique que twitter
c'est pas le endroit pour avoir des
débats
j'ai souvent cette critique que les
repas de famille c'est pas le bon format
de débats ou faut réfléchir à comment
avoir un certain format de débats oui
oui je pense qu'il ya des réflexions
intéressantes à faire là-dessus mais je
pense que c'est pas la priorité parce
que la priorité c'est d'améliorer les je
pense que la manière dont les gens débat
en pratique et les débats en pratique
pas assez les repas de famille ces
discussions autour d'un verre c'est à
twitter c'est youtube c'est facebook et
du coup je pense que c'est directement
sur ses différentes plateformes dans ses
différents formats de débats qu'il faut
essayer d'avoir une modification
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle je
n'apporte pas ses sujets je me trompe
peut-être et j'ai eu pas mal de
discussions nous pensons aucune
discussion n'a fait changer d'avis sur
la priorité à donner au format de débats
de façon générale mais bien sûr
peut-être que je me trompe mais en tout
cas si c'est un sujet que vous pensez
important je voudrais aussi à faire
votre propre vos propres vidéos à ce
sujet et essayer de promouvoir grand la
réflexion autour de ces formats de
débats et du coup peut-être le point le
plus fin qu'un des points importants
aussi que je vais peut-être promouvoir
d'abord et sur les prochaines heures et
prochains mois et ce sur quoi je finis
en tout cas ce probablement qui pour le
coup serait du coup incroyablement cours
pour rapport probablement habituel
mais pas besoin d'avoir un format tour
même en tout cas un des points sur
lequel vraiment je laissais de
j'aimerais essayer de donner plus les
gens à faire c'est pas directement mieux
débattre mais s'est également faite à
mener sur tous les gens à réfléchir à
comment mieux débattre
bien sûr la mise en pratique est
également importante
mais pour un sens le truc plus déficient
parce que je pense que cette volonté de
mise en pratique elle existe un peu et
pas d'autres équipes sont encore plus
déficient aujourd'hui c'est la volonté à
réfléchir à comment mieux débattre parce
que encore une fois je pense qu'il ya
énormément de choses à dire et je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup d'ignorance sur
comment mieux débattre et du cou à
commencer par moi bien sûr
et du coup j'aimerais vraiment encouragé
vraiment une réflexion collective sur
comment mener débattre finalement le
méta de métal de débattre de mieux
débattre il est inutile juste tellement
pertinent c'est un petit peu dommage
mais oui je pense qu'il ya besoin d'être
beaucoup beaucoup dans le métal il doit
réfléchir à comment réfléchir et de
réfléchir collectivement comment mieux
réfléchir collectivement et c'est
vraiment un des trucs que je vais
continuer et encore plus promouvoir dans
l'année qui vient
voilà j'ai fait un peu le tour de la
question s'il ya des trucs qui que j'ai
oublié
vous ne semblez fin qui selon vous ce
correspondant
les trucs que j'ai pas mentionné mais
qui sont importants qui sont possibles
importance ont changé la manière dont
son débat et qu'ils vont faire beaucoup
de bien aux importants dans le sens où
ces petites solutions qui marchent pas
très bien et qu'il faudrait davantage
pour voir parce qu'on sait que ça marche
pas très bien mais je les ai pas promu
bon voyez cette histoire d'entretien
pré-liste mikko si je n'ai parlé aussi
avec anthony magnier bosco vraiment son
truc
mais voilà si c'est d'autres choses
aussi des solutions mais aussi qu'ils
sont peut-être négligé ce n'a pas assez
parlé
et pour nous les gens ont tendance à ne
pas assez parlé et qui gagneraient à
être davantage pour mieux faites moi
savoir
lâche entre 1,2 pour ceux qui savent pas
je en train d'utiliser la grille de
lecture de la tribune fille casse en
termes de échelle facile à résoudre et à
quelqu'un c'est d'exiger qu'ils sont
très très utiles en pratique à mettre en
avant
s'il ya d'autres aspects des attendus
qui correspondent à ces critères et que
je n'ai pas mentionné
ben je mérite vraiment les mettre dans
les commentaires et à me faire réfléchir
à comment mieux réfléchir
2 comment mieux réfléchir collectivement
à comment mieux réfléchir collectivement
hashtag bêta de medal